[Musique]
c'est souvent je vois des gens qui
je descends mais je n'ai jamais osé
demander ce qui se passe
il n'y a plus d'après à saint germain
des prés les caps ont déserté les
branches et de la nuit ont envahi les
catacombes
il y à un après à saint germain des prés
salés à nos lampes au bec et bottes de
caoutchouc dernier chic pour serra
tschopp 300 km de tunnels pour épater la
galerie 35 mètres sous terre dans les
anciennes carrières de paris la ville
bâtie sur du vide en a interdites pour
des rencontres insolites docteur
livingstone ou mister dracula
mais attention danger
pénétrer dans les catacombes est à la
portée de tout le monde s'y perdre se
laisser surprendre par la montée des
eaux également
première étape à la recherche de lost
perdus l'initiation de tout premiers
visiteurs
vas-y on va marcher ensemble on a tous
envie vendée au quoi alors qu'on veut
voir les carrières on va avoir les eaux
ici aucun dox les catacombes les
catacombes c'est un petit peu l'endroit
où on met les morts il ya fin xviiie
siècle ils ont vidé les cimetières de
paris ils ont descendu ça dans les
catacombes officiel 6 millions de
parisiens c'est à dire autant de
parisiens mots sous forme d'os comme sa
cote parisienne de ce qu'ils vivent
au bout du tunnel lh aventure
frissons garantis derrière chaque pilier
les jeux de rôle la dernière lubie des
étudiants parisiens
judex me ramener parmi les thèmes de la
mort
est-ce que c'est là le tous ces monstres
qui autour de nous les jeux auxquels
football s'est inspiré d'un jeu drôle de
navrant et dragon lui monstres sont joue
le rôle de monstres et les aventuriers
il s'agit de les tuer à l'aide d'une
arme
l'appareil photo
les cats à condom aussi leurs martyrs
aux recoins d'une galerie philibert
asper s'est perdu dans les carrières en
on a retrouvé son corps onze ans plus
tard il est mort de soif
on vient lui rendre un dernier hommage
en bougeant à sa santé il y avait des
amis qui partait faire une promenade
dans les catacombes et à la lune vous
allez je crois le sueur par la bonne il
sentait une odeur bizarre
bon ils n'ont pas cherché à savoir
qu'est ce que c'était et au retour alors
qu'il voulait les s'isoler un peu ils
ont suivi l'odeur par son stand bio
fromages comme ça arrive de temps en
temps ils ont trouvé un accord avec
quelques coups de fusil dont ventre
au bout de chaque galerie il ya toujours
un tunnel qui mène un souterrain qui
aboutit à une galerie au milieu de l'une
d'entre elles
la piscine sous l'hôpital cochin qu'est
ce que justement c'est la fontaine
sainte marie ici d'ailleurs probablement
l'eau la plus claire de paris peut-être
la plus pure
les téméraires la goutte les autres s'y
baignent tu mon disque ya le côté il ya
un mur
j'ai un bon jour enfin parce que vous
faites comme vous venez de vous êtes
allez vous dans mon métier délais de
paiement c'est un cul de sac
vous connaissez bien là le coin on est
venus de trois fois déjà
rage
pour accéder à la salle z
le chemin est balisé tunnel en enfilade
pour talons aiguilles et bas résille six
femmes et à droite
[Musique]
non
allez
le samedi soir aussi bondée qu'un grand
magasin la veille de noël rencontres
assuré ambiance pas toujours garanti
punk et bon chic bon genre
l'hôpital du val de grâce à déverser ses
vieilles radiographies le secret
militaire en prend un coup
boîte crânienne avec le
alors passer son dossier arrive il a une
présence du nouveau cycle positif de
tonalité regarde lui les malades suva ja
on appelle ça le ciel de la carrière
c'est le toit quoi il est tout le monde
écrit son nom ici et partout on se
balade on voit des noms watteau tôt par
là on voit moi je fais une flèche ici
pour pour que les gens qui sont perdus
pour qu'il se retrouve on se perd dans
les catacombes
le ciel le sol se ressemblent
on suit des fil d'ariane qui ne mène
nulle part il prend la direction
problème c'est que je sais pas si je
suis à droite ou à gauche de la kz2
direction principale et ça moi je suis
même beaucoup mais on retrouve une
plaque de rue qu'elle indique malgré
walter notre guide sa boussole ses plans
sa connaissance des lieux nous avons
erré pendant trois heures
oui
labrie allemand des heures de marche
pour quelques inscriptions et de vieux
morceaux de bois les restes d'un central
téléphonique de l'occupant
[Musique]
non loin de là labrie français une cache
des résistants de rol tanguy
aujourd'hui passage obligé des bizuths
des grandes écoles du quartier latin
dans ces souterrains il n'y a plus de
marginaux la nuit tous les chats sont
gris et les souris dansent
face à lui
on avait été au courant mise au courant
de quelque chose qui se passait quelque
part alors on a été voir et on est tombé
sans de soirée bon et puis comme ça nous
a beaucoup plu on s'est dit il faut
qu'on fasse la même chose alors pour le
même endroit parce que ça ne convenait
pas tellement on connaît ça me les
endroits et dès qu'on a pu on a fait
cette soirée
m
[Musique]
west ham est confiant il ya trop de
monde
beaucoup trop de monde ya trop de
lumière et c'est pas très rigolo
alors qu'est ce qui est rigolo
d'habitués rigolo de venir à 10
personnes se promener de partir à
l'aventuré s'amuser de la centrale et la
basse et c'est comme dans une boîte
comme d'un concert la même ambiance et
même jean qu'ailleurs c'est pas vraiment
rigolo alors qu'est ce que vous faites
d'habitude je suis dedans qu'on va se
terminer par l'aventuré pas beaucoup un
petit coup il y a quelque chose de
pourri au royaume des ténèbres
[Musique]